we left off in the last video in the
archaean eon and where arche comes from
ancient greek it means beginning or
origin and it's the eon in which either
life first started to exist or at least
it first started to somewhat flourish
it's possible that maybe life first
started to exist at the end of the
hedeen eon and of course this boundary
is
is vague and the archaeanian is also the
first eon where we still have rocks from
that time so we are able to find rocks
that we can date to be roughly 3.8
billion years now the other really
interesting thing that happened in the
archaean eon it really has a pretty
profound effects once we get into the
proterozoic eon is that you started to
have psionic cyanobacteria
produce oxygen and we said in the last
video that they were producing oxygen
but most of that oxygen was being
absorbed by iron in the oceans but what
happens is we enter into the proterozoic
eon and proterozoic eon
it's right over here i don't know if you
can see that i'll rewrite it
proteroproterozoic
we're now in the proterozoic eon
that starts up about 2.5 billion years
ago and proterozoic comes from the greek
for earlier life
earlier
earlier life and i'm not a greek scholar
so i i you know any of you greeks out
there forgive me if i'm not getting the
translation exactly right but what's
really interesting at the
proterozoic eon is that that oxygen that
was being produced by the cyanobacteria
and at some point begins to saturate the
iron and any other molecule that could
have absorbed it before and once it
saturates it starts to get released into
the atmosphere
so the oxygen starts to get released and
accumulate in the atmosphere and we
think this happened that started to
happen about 2.4 billion years ago so
2.4
billion years ago
oxygen begins to accumulate in the
atmosphere and of course you know these
dates they might be moved around a few
hundred million years as you get more
and more data but this is the current
understanding of when things happen and
maybe we'll look at the geological
record of the fossil record and we'll
move these things around in the future i
could only imagine that 50 years from
now or 100 years from now if someone's
still watching this video a lot of this
might say hey you know we found out
later that oxygen started to accumulate
in the atmosphere earlier or later or
that eukaryotes occurred earlier later
but this as far as i can tell is our
best current understanding but 2.4
billion years ago oxygen
begins
begins
to accumulate
accumulate in the atmosphere and what's
interesting about this is once it
accumulates it once it gets kind of a
critical
amount of oxygen in the atmosphere and i
touched on this in the last video about
2.3 billion years ago we have something
called the great oxygenation event
sometimes called the oxygen catastrophe
and this is right here they market on
this right here 2.3 billion years ago or
2 300 million years ago atmosphere
becomes oxygen rich it's not as oxygen
rich as our current atmosphere
but it becomes oxygen rich enough that
at least the environment becomes
suitable for eukaryotic organisms or
eukaryotic cell now the other
interesting thing and we might not care
so much about it because we needed the
oxygen is that we think that this was
actually the greatest extinction event
in the history of earth that's why it's
called the oxygen catastrophe so this
right over here 2.3 billion years ago i
shouldn't giggle about it this is a
serious matter it's the greatest
greatest extinction event
extinction
event in earth's history
in history and i'll do history with a
capital h in earth's in the history of
the earth and that's because you know
the cyanobacteria is producing all this
oxygen eventually saturates the iron it
accumulates in the air once it gets to
enough concentration it begins to
actually suffocate it's poisonous it's
poisonous to most of the other organisms
on the planet that were that were
anaerobic that did not need oxygen that
actually found oxygen that actually
found oxygen poisonous
now but since we have actually there's
two interesting things that happened
once that oxygen accumulated other than
causing this mass extinction event
actually three interesting things two of
them are essentially are crucial to us
eventually showing up on this planet the
first is is that it became suitable now
for eukaryotes to exist eukaryotic
organisms remember these are organisms
that have that have nuclear membranes
around their dna most eukaryotes have
other organelles like mitochondria they
need oxygen
they
they need
they need oxygen you can go to the
biology playlist we actually talk about
respiration that occurs in the
mitochondria and that's obviously a
process that needs oxygen so one we have
now that oxygen is in the atmosphere
we're starting to have an environment
where eukaryotes could at least exist
and based on the fossil records and when
we look at you know how the dna has
changed over time and we'll do multiple
videos of that we think we think that
the first eukaryotes showed up about 2.2
billion years ago although there's some
debate here there's some evidence that
might have been a little earlier some
evidence it might have been later i'm
sure that number will be refined but
about you know
give or take a few hundred millions of
years
one prokaryote got engulfed by another
prokaryote said hey we do pretty well
living together i mean a lot of
the current theory is that mitochondria
is actually descendant from
the
the current theory is that mitochondria
is actually descended from a kind of an
ancient prokaryotic cell an ancient
bacteria it actually has its own dna and
actually your mitochondrial dna is
passed down from your mother and your
mother's mother and your mother's mother
so on and so forth so it's kind of like
another little animal living inside of a
larger cell and we are eukaryotes we
needed this to happen our your the human
body we're not just one eukaryotic cell
we're made up of trillions estimates are
50 to 100 trillion eukaryotic cells so
this was a super these are our ancestors
that had to come into being at that time
and once again all of this is happening
inside of the oceans
now the other interesting thing that
happened remember we're being bombarded
with uv radiation from the sun so if
you're on the land
so if you're on the land let me draw the
land in the ocean
so
here is the ocean
and then here is the land
here is the land right over there in
yellow
constantly being bombarded with uv
radiation
and uv stands for ultraviolet so i'm
drawing it in purple but it's even more
violet than purple
so it's constantly being bombarded by
with ultraviolet radiation from the sun
which is very inhospitable to dna and to
life and so the only life at this point
could occur in the ocean where it was
protected to some degree from the
ultraviolet
radiation the land was just open to it
you were getting anything on the land
would have just gotten irradiated its
dna would get mutated just would not be
able to live so what happened and what i
guess has to happen and the reason why
we are able to live on land now is that
we have an ozone layer
we have an ozone layer up
in the upper atmosphere that helps
absorb that
that blocks most of the uv radiation
from the sun and now that oxygen began
to accumulate we have the oxygen
catastrophe oxygen accumulates in the
atmosphere some of that at some of that
oxygen goes into the upper atmosphere so
we're now in this time period right over
here it goes into the upper atmosphere
it actually reacts with the uv light to
turn into ozone which then can
help actually block the uv light and
i'll do another video maybe on the ozone
on the ozone oxygen cycle so this this
oxygen production it's crucial one to
having an ozone layer so that eventually
life can exist on the land and it's also
crucial because eukaryotic organisms
need that oxygen now the third thing
that happened this is also a pretty
significant event
we believe
we believe that that oxygen that started
to accumulate in the atmosphere reacted
with methane in the atmosphere so it
reacted with methane and methane is an
ozone it it's a no no it's a greenhouse
gas it helps retain heat in the
atmosphere and once it reacts with the
oxygen and starts dropping out of the
atmosphere as methane we believe the
earth cooled down and it entered its
first and some people believe its
longest snowball period so that's why
what they talk about right here on this
diagram the first
the first snowball earth it's sometimes
called the huronic glaciation and that
happened because we weren't able to
retain our heat if that theory is
correct and so the whole the as the
theory goes the whole earth essentially
just iced over so as we kind of as we go
through the proterozoic
eon i guess the the the big markers of
it is it's the first time that we now
have an oxygen-rich atmosphere it's the
first time that eukaryotes are uh can
now come into existence because they
they have they now have oxygen the two i
guess we could say breathe
and the other big thing is now this is
where the ozone forms so this kind of
sets the stage for in the next eon for
animals or or living things to
eventually get on to the land and we'll
talk about that in the next video